Hi, welcome back, and thank you for your interest in learning more about translucent materials.
In this class, we'll review our agenda for the upcoming lessons, and then we'll develop
a translucent material from an empty and sad material graph.
Alright, let's go.
So as I just anticipated, in the first module we'll explore the creation of a translucent
material.
We'll be starting out with some ground theory on the Fresnel effect, understanding what
it is, especially in relation to glass shaders.
Once the theory is covered, we'll be ready to develop our first translucent material.
In the next video, we'll be uncovering how to customize these translucent materials
using decals to fake reflections and looks.
Then we're also going to look into developing bump offset materials in engine using the
noise node, which is a node we haven't really explored yet, so that's going to be new
for you guys.
And to conclude this first module, we'll dial up the complexity knob and learn how
to create a blurred glass effect using the spiral blur material function.
Then in the second module of this class, we'll uncover the concept of shading models
by looking at two-sided foliage shaders in particular.
We'll break down some theory again on shader models and their properties, as well as developing
a wind effect in a two-sided shader model.
We'll be concluding this course with material functions and creating a dissolve transition
material.
We'll learn how to use bounding box and dot product nodes.
Then we'll check out how to wrap up this dissolve effect into a parent material, a
material function, and then make an instance out of it to make it real versatile.
Okay, cool, let's get started with some Fresnel theory now.
So the Fresnel effect makes surfaces more or less reflective depending on the glancing
angles at which you look at that object from.
And in Unreal Engine shading models, this is built into most materials automatically.
So when you create a material, it calculates how reflective surfaces should be based on
their viewing angles.
Also just so you know, the Fresnel effect is a core component of the PBR.
The PBR system aims to simulate how light actually behaves in the real world.
And the Fresnel is actually one of those real-world behaviors.
The engine does a pretty good job already at replicating it automatically based on the
base color, metallic, roughness, and specular properties of an material.
And as you can see in these percentages down here on the left, at direct angles
like at around 0 degrees, you see more base color and texture.
And at shallow angles closer to 90 degrees, you see more reflections.
And for most materials like plastic, metal, or water, the default behavior of the Fresnel
already handles this effect correctly.
But we can actually customize and adjust these values by tweaking the Fresnel node,
which we'll talk about in just a moment.
So the one in this slide is a typical example to understanding the Fresnel effect.
Imagine you're looking straight down at a pool or a lake.
You won't see a lot of reflections in the water.
But if you adjust your head and get more parallel to the water surface, you'll see more and
more reflections in it.
And the pool will behave almost like a mirror, reflecting the sky or anything around it.
The Fresnel node lets you customize three main properties.
The exponent in, the base reflect fraction in, which is a whole tongue twister and
I challenge you to post the video now and try pronouncing it yourself.
Okay, welcome back.
And then the normal.
You can trick these values through simple float parameters or by connecting entire series
of nodes to them, depending on what you want to achieve in your material.
Let's review for a moment the Fresnel index up close.
The Fresnel node can be pretty much connected to any kind of input in the main material
node, like the emissive, the subsurface, the roughness, the specular, metallic, and
the normal.
And each one of these outputs, of course, will output a different effect.
This is as far as we'll go with the slides, but remember that each step that
I will be taking in Unreal will also be displayed through screenshots and instructions
here in the slides, so you can easily follow along.
So let's jump into the engine and create our first translucent material.
Okay, we're in the translucent object section of our default map that should be firing
up whenever you open the project for the first time.
And here we can take a look at the three examples we'll be dealing with today.
We'll be starting with reviewing a very simple glass material, then see how this tinted,
thin glass was made.
And then lastly, this complex glass material.
If you move the camera around, you can really see how the different indexes of refraction
play a role here in the way that these surfaces react to their environments.
And it's pretty cool.
Before diving deeper in the creation of our first translucent material, I just wanted
to show you something quickly because it's important to mention it.
So if we click up here on this lit button, we will be able to change our view mode.
Right now it's lit, which is the default kind of view mode.
But if we go down to optimization view modes, we can see the shader complexity.
And if we click on it, Unreal Engine will provide us with an overview of how complex
the shaders in our map are, starting from green, which is good, and then leading to
pink and light pink, which really means that those materials are eating up a lot of
our system resources.
So any translucent material we have in this map really requires a lot of computational
power.
And this is important to keep in mind for optimization purposes, especially if you're
interested in developing or optimizing environments for video games.
Okay, let's switch back the view mode to lit.
And then we can click our first preview mesh.
And here down in the details panel, we can open up the glass material.
Alright, so the first thing I want to do is just click in an empty area of the graph
to show you that the blend mode of the main material was changed from its default
value, which is opaque, to translucent.
I'm going to be clicking on this arrow over here to reset the blend mode to the
default value, which is opaque as we just said.
And as you can see here, the opacity input of the material node was grayed out.
And that's because we need to change the blend mode to translucent or additive in
order for us to customize the opacity properties of this material.
Alright, there is another thing we need to keep in mind when working with translucent
materials.
And that's the lighting mode that we can find down here.
Now, right now the lighting mode is set to surface translucency volume.
And that's the reason why we can change the specularity, the roughness, and the
metallic properties of our material.
And the surface translucency volume and the surface forward shading are actually the
most complex kind of lighting modes you can have.
The simplest one is the volumetric non-directional.
And if we turn that on, switching it back to its default value, we don't have access
to the metallic, specular, and roughness properties of the material anymore.
So the material will stay translucent, but it will be limited in its capacity.
Let's switch it back to translucency volume.
And here we have the input pins available again.
Now you can see here that we also have the refraction index available to customize
in this material.
And this is something that is not enabled by default.
So if we go here in the search bar, we can type refraction.
You can see that the refraction method was changed from the default value, which is none,
to index of refraction.
A refraction method set to none prevents us from being able to change the refraction
index of a material.
And if we switch it back to index of refraction, we will be able to customize it to our liking.
Okay, so just so you know, this feature level switch is a bit of an advanced node.
And it lets us switch between different quality settings based on the hardware capabilities
of the device running a game, for example.
So in the case of a mobile phone or an older computer, the feature level switch would be
switching the shading model from SM6 or SM5 to PS 3.1, for example, which is commonly
used for mobiles.
But this is quite of an advanced concept and we want to dive deeper into this.
So the last thing I want to show you is the translucency pass advanced option that
you can change here, which basically lets you specify whether this particular translucent
material needs to be rendered before the depth of field, after the depth of field,
or after the motion blur.
So sometimes when you're rendering a translucent material with depth of field from a cinematic
camera or any kind of camera in Unreal Engine, it will be badly sorted compared to what
you have in your map.
This translucency pass lets you alter that.
Probably before depth of field works in most of the cases, but in case you're struggling
with that, here is this option.
So let's go back to our map now and create our first translucent material.
I'm going to be right-clicking on the Content Browser and then add a new material
and we can call it M underscore Translucent.
Then I will double-click on it to open it up.
And here again, we'll do the first three steps that I just outlined in the simple glass
material.
So we'll be changing the blend mode from opaque to translucent, and this will give
us access to the opacity, but we'll gray out the metallic, specular, and roughness,
which we want to have available in this case.
So if we scroll down, we have the lighting mode.
And here we can switch from volumetric non-directional to surface forward shading.
Okay, this enables the metallic, specular, and roughness properties of our material.
Now we just need a refraction, which is disabled.
So let's just type refraction here in the details search bar and change the refraction
method from none to index of refraction.
All right, we're going to keep things simple over here.
So I'm going to press three on my keyboard and then click in an emptier of the graph
to create a constant tree vector.
And then I'm going to color it gray, but you can really color it however you like
and plug this output pane to the base color.
It's going to take a second for Unreal to compute the changes that we made because as
we just mentioned, translucent materials tend to be quite heavy on our hardware.
So then we want to be promoting two parameters, the metallic, specular, and roughness properties
of our material.
So let's right click on each one of them and promote two parameters.
Okay, we'll be setting the metallic to 0.5, but really whatever you feel like.
The specular to one, and the roughness, we can keep it at zero.
And then we'll promote two parameter, the opacity as well.
And I'm going to set it to 0.5.
Feel free to experiment around with these values if you want to.
The more you experiment, the better you're going to learn these concepts.
Okay, let's now take care of the refraction index and customize it a little bit to
our liking.
So I'm going to right click in an emptier of the graph and then type in the search
bar Fresnel.
And here I have the chance to adding either a Fresnel node or a Fresnel function.
We're going to be looking into the Fresnel function node in the upcoming classes.
So for now, let's just keep it simple and use the Fresnel node instead.
Okay, now we want to right click on exponent in and then promote to parameter.
I'm just going to be setting it to a high value like 10.
So now we're going to be adding a lerp node by typing L on the keyboard and left clicking
on the graph.
And the Fresnel node will be driving the alpha mask between the A and the B inputs
of the linear interpolate node.
So let's press one on the keyboard and add a constant value that will change to one
and connect it to the A. Then right click on the B and promote that to a parameter
that we're going to be calling refraction.
Okay, and let's set the refraction to something like 1.4.
Okay, we can plug the lerp node to the refraction value.
And if we move the value of the refraction around, we can really see how the reflection
on the surface wraps differently based on our refraction value.
And that's pretty cool to see.
Okay, this was our first translucent material.
And now I'm just going to hit save to apply all my changes.
And let's go back to our viewport to review the other two materials we have at our disposal
over here.
The first one is the painted thin material.
So I'm just going to be clicking on the preview mesh and down here in the details,
I can find this simple glass material.
Okay, so we won't dive too deep into this because we'll look at it further in the
ray tracing class.
But the first thing we notice if we click in an empty area of the graph is that the
blend mode of this material is set to translucent just like it was for the simple glass.
But the shading model is set to thin translucent, which is a very specific kind of shading
model that was recently introduced in the engine.
And thin translucent shading models help us create realistic see-through materials
like tinted glass or plastic.
Now you can see here that we have metallic specular and roughness exposed.
So you can already guess that the lighting mode was changed here to surface forward
shading.
Okay, so in order for us to be able to use thin translucent materials, we need to
add a thin translucent material output expression.
And there can be just one in the graph at a time.
So in this case, we have two and Unreal is giving us an error.
Then we can really plug in here any color or constant three vector or any kind of nodes
that we want to stain our tinted glass material.
I'm going to be deleting that.
And now let's go back to our viewport and review the most complex of the three
glass materials.
So I'm going to be clicking on this preview mesh.
Then down here, I get access to the material instance of the complex glass.
Let's review the parent node real quick by clicking on its parent material.
Okay, so the main idea behind this complex glass is really similar to what we just applied
to the simple glass material, but it was expanded much further.
So we took this Fresnel node and then we used it as alpha input to all these lerp nodes
that are mapping the minimum and maximum properties of this main material.
And we can really see it in action in the material instance, especially in the refraction
mean and max values.
We can really start seeing how the Fresnel node is being affected and affecting the
opacity between the mean and max parameters of each surface properties.
And that's really, really cool.
Okay, that was it for the in-engine session of this video.
Let's switch back to the slides to conclude the class.
Okay, that was it for this class, but you can find some additional documentation at
this link if you're interested in further expanding your knowledge in material properties.
Thanks for sticking around, and in the upcoming lesson, we will look into faking
effects when it comes to translucent objects, as well as other advanced translucent features.
See you there.